the for the I would I would say the last
time you were up here uh at the show was
maybe like a year ago and I don't think
you would really try shrooms yet and I
gave you some shrooms
you said you you've had some pretty
serious trips yeah talk about some of
the crazier trips you've had on
psilocybin so far man so my recent trip
I was just saying um not too long ago
was um I was literally laying in Miami I
was in Miami and I was I was grounded
with Earth and I I just laid down and um
took a few shrooms like a handful of
them and um
so when I speak on certain out of body
experiences you got to speak on it it's
like a spiritual sense because it's way
beyond the physical but in a spiritual
sense I was laying down and it's like
the top of my head opened up so of
course it didn't open up physically
right it opened up in a spiritual sense
um it opens up and then like my hair in
the spiritual sense it rolls up and
connected like a dread and formed one
dread real strong right so I felt my
hair was like my antenna that kept me
grounded between my body and where I was
going in the spiritual realm so my hair
I felt it it was like like a strong one
dread just keeping me attached to my
body as I went to where I went to and um
I know for a fact it was my son that
came and took me on that Journey because
my son RP told him he he got miscarried
his name's seven so um my son pretty
much took me on a journey to a woman's
womb I don't know if it was the womb I
was president or if it was the womb that
he was president in before he miscarried
so I was in a womb and um
I felt the most unconditional loving
soothing and just beautiful type of
feeling it wasn't nothing I saw it was
more so of what I felt and the feeling
was so beautiful after I got back to
Consciousness on a 3D level when I got
up I cried and it was so beautiful
because
within that process I realized how
important women are within that process
I realized how important a healthy
pregnancy is I realized um that God is
literally forming you in that stomach
and literally pouring every sense of
Personality Talent
um everything until you while you're in
that room
um and fourthly I realized the heaven
state that was Heaven I feel like I felt
the presence of God and nothing mattered
in that space like nothing like if I
could stay there forever I would stay
there it was that beautiful you know wow
would you suggest other people trying
shrooms because I feel like you wouldn't
suggest other people I want to suggest
everyone because they I feel like
they'll take too much at one time and
just go on a trip but I do suggest if
people want to get into it to start off
with a very very small adult overdose
yeah micro dosing to it and then going
on that Journey you got to get your feet
wet which you gotta you can't just dive
all the way in because then you're
you'll freak out yeah for sure but I do
recommend people to start with
meditation first because I started with
meditation and then everything started
to open up for me so if you're wanting
to take shrooms or psychedelics whatever
I say start with meditation and being
able to get to a certain level of
Consciousness with just your breath
first and then implement the things that
God said for you